Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Si se alinearan todos los vasos
sanguíneos de tu cuerpo,
hablaríamos de 95 000 kilómetros,
que bombean todos
los días el equivalente
a más de 7500 litros de sangre,
aunque esos litros son en realidad
los mismos 4 o 5 litros
reciclados una y otra vez,
que ayudan a la distribución de
oxígeno y nutrientes preciosos
como la glucosa y los aminoácidos
a los tejidos corporales.
Toda esa sangre ejerce una fuerza
sobre las paredes musculares
de los vasos sanguíneos.
Esa fuerza se llama presión arterial,
y sube y baja al ritmo
de los latidos del corazón.
Es más alta durante la sístole,
cuando el corazón se contrae
para bombear la sangre por las arterias.
Esta es la presión arterial sistólica.
Cuando el corazón se encuentra
en reposo entre latidos,
la presión arterial se reduce hasta su
valor más bajo, la presión diastólica.
Cualquier individuo sano
tiene una presión sistólica
de entre 90 y 120 milímetros de mercurio,
y una presión diastólica de entre 60 y 80.
Tomadas en conjunto, una lectura normal
es un poco menos de 120 con 80.
La sangre atraviesa todo el cuerpo
a través de los vasos
del sistema circulatorio.
Como en cualquier trabajo de fontanería
hay varias cosas que pueden aumentar
la fuerza sobre las paredes de los vasos:
las propiedades del fluido, otros fluidos
adicionales, o unos vasos más estrechos.
Así que, si la sangre se espesa,
hace falta una mayor
presión para bombearla,
por lo que el corazón
bombeará con más fuerza.
Una dieta alta en sal conducirá
a un resultado similar.
La sal favorece la retención de agua,
y el exceso de líquido aumenta el
volumen sanguíneo y la presión arterial,
mientras que el estrés,
la respuesta de "defensa o huida"
libera hormonas como la
epinefrina y la norepinefrina
que constriñen los vasos principales,
aumentando la resistencia
al flujo y la presión.
Los vasos sanguíneos pueden lidiar
normalmente con estas
fluctuaciones de manera fácil.
Las fibras elásticas incrustadas en
sus paredes los hacen resistentes,
pero si su presión arterial se eleva
por encima de los 140 con 90,
lo que llamamos la hipertensión,
y se mantiene en estos niveles,
puede causar serios problemas.
Eso es porque la tensión adicional
creada en la pared arterial
puede producir pequeños desgarros.
Cuando el tejido dañado se hincha,
las sustancias que responden
para arreglar la inflamación,
como los leucocitos,
se depositan alrededor de los desgarros.
Y la grasa y el colesterol que flotan
en la sangre se pegan, también,
hasta llegar a formar una placa
que se vuelve rígida y espesa
la pared arterial interior.
Esta condición se llama aterosclerosis,
y puede tener consecuencias peligrosas.
Si la placa se rompe, un coágulo de sangre
que se forme en la parte
superior del desgarro
puede obstruir la arteria ya estrecha.
Si el coágulo es lo
suficientemente grande
puede bloquear completamente
el flujo de oxígeno y nutrientes
a las células del resto del cuerpo.
Su presencia en los vasos
que alimentan el corazón
causará un ataque al corazón,
cuando las células musculares cardíacas
privadas de oxígeno comienzan a morir.
Si el coágulo obstaculiza el flujo
de sangre hacia el cerebro
puede provocar un
accidente cerebrovascular.
Estos vasos sanguíneos
obstruidos pueden ampliarse
a través de un procedimiento
llamado angioplastia.
Los médicos introducen un hilo
de alambre a través del vaso sanguíneo
hasta al sitio obstruido,
y luego colocan un catéter de globo
desinflado sobre el alambre.
Cuando se infla el globo,
obliga a abrir paso de nuevo.
A veces un tubo rígido
llamado endoprótesis
se coloca para mantener los
vasos sanguíneos abiertos
y dejar que el flujo de sangre
circule libremente
para reponer a las células
privadas de oxígeno.
Mantenerse flexible bajo presión
es un trabajo duro para las arterias.
El fluido que ellas bombean
se compone de sustancias
pegajosas y que las pueden obstruir,
mientras que un corazón sano
late unas 70 veces por minuto
y durante al menos 2,5 millones
de veces en una vida media.
Puede parecer que se trata
de una presión impresionante
pero no te preocupes, tus arterias
son muy adecuadas para este desafío.